the most ridiculous reaction from the
jessie smollett incident
came from the actress ellen page now
she's pretending to be a boy named
elliot page but back during the time of
the jessie smilet thing she acknowledged
that she's a woman named ellen page and
she went on stephen colbert's late night
show and she blamed i'm not joking she
blamed the jesse smilet attack which is
which was totally real
on
vice president mike pence
and the vice president mike pence who
like wishes i couldn't be married let's
just be clear
the vice president of america wishes i
didn't have the love with my wife
he wanted to ban that in indiana
he believes in conversion therapy
he has hurt lgbtq people so badly as the
government of indiana and i think the
thing we need to know and i hope my show
gaycation did this in terms of
connecting the dots in terms of what
happened the other day did you see i
don't know him personally i saw i send
all of my love
connect the dots
this is what happens
if you are in a position of power and
you hate people
and you want to cause suffering to them
you go through the trouble you spend
your career trying to cause suffering
what do you think is gonna happen what
do you think is gonna happen
what do you think was what i think
happened is that white supremacists on
the south side of chicago tried to lynch
jesse smallette i connected the dots
except
from dot to dot to dot to dot
in ellen page's mind
the dots were based on lies
that's the problem she did connect the
dots she connected the dots
of her false premises
starting with the idea that america's
this angry evil terrible place where
straight white men are just trying to
kill everybody
and going all the way back to the dot
that men and women are exactly the same
she connected all of those dots
and she ended up at the place where
jesse smellet got attacked by white
supremacists in chicago
if you start wrong
you're going to end up in a very very
very wrong place connect
the dots
i think we need to connect the dots
nothing that ellen page said is true
about mike pence or about jesus millet
or about anyone else
mike i don't want to speak for mike
pence i don't know mike pence i'm not
his spokesman but i suspect what mike
pence would say about the accusation
that she doesn't
he doesn't want her to get married to
her lady or whatever is that
he
has no opinion about her getting married
to her lady
other than it is not possible for her to
get married to her lady no matter what
the supreme court said no matter what
anthony kennedy said it's not possible
because marriage involves sexual
difference it does and it's not like you
hate gay guys or women or it's just
because it's just what we're talking
about earlier because men and women are
different it's not possible and i'm i'm
sorry ellen page that i can't change
reality for you to make that possible
and i'm sorry that not even anthony
kennedy on the supreme court can change
reality to make that possible for you
and no one's saying that you can't have
affection for this lady or vice versa
and no one's even saying that you can't
do whatever you got i don't know
whatever you guys do but you know i no
one is even saying that
we're just saying that the reality of
marriage and marriage is again just
we're just talking about one institution
one natural institution but there are
many others the reality of these things
cannot be made to bend to your
misunderstanding and your will
and your desires it it just
can't happen
okay
and so if
if you went all the way back and you
said you know
actually
men and women actually are different
and mike pence doesn't it's not he hates
me
and it's not that this is an evil
tyrannical place because the people who
want to acknowledge reality
are
you know they just they're filled with
bile and malevolence and it's just that
you know there is this thing is reality
and it's a fallen broken world and we've
all got to deal with that
if you connected all those dots then you
would look at the incident that happened
with jesse smallat his fake attack and
you would just laugh about it like dave
chappelle did
like remember dave chappelle called it
at the time he was like this isn't real
this is not
uh i don't think so so do you remember
okay
do you remember that dave chappelle had
this special come out around the time
and he referred to this french actor
jesse sommelier take a listen
don't ever forget what happened to that
french actor
you know what i'm talking about
juicy smoothies very french very famous
french actor
y'all never heard of jesus
okay so i have an unpopular admission to
make which is i never got why this line
is all that funny i thought the bit was
funny i thought that dave chappelle
talking about
how jesse obviously that this wasn't
real in chicago come on it's chicago
guys give me a break
i thought that whole thing was funny but
pronouncing his name in a french accent
i've never understood why that is funny
i know that's an unpopular take everyone
gets a big kick out of it at first i
thought the reason he was doing it was
to distance himself from jesse smellette
in that like i dave chappelle i'm a
black man and jesse smellette is a black
man but i'm embarrassed by what this
black man has done so i want to separate
us as much as possible so i'm going to
call him a frenchman but then he refers
to him as a black guy so anyway that bit
that's just a little bit of a digression
here but the point that dave made
was absolutely right
because dave chappelle
more than many people in our culture
has at least some grasp on reality
and so he knew i i don't think so i
don't think
that that's really
going to happen it's not hateful
it's not mean it's not cruel it's not
mike pence walking around with
electrodes trying to just zap anybody
that he doesn't like it's not cruel to
say look there are realities here
and we just have to deal with that and
in a broken world that's going to be
difficult for us sometimes and there's
going to be suffering and that's just
the way the world works is that there's
suffering and we need to take that
suffering and have it be sanctifying and
edifying for us
or we can have some dude beat all the
chicks in the women's swim meets
and and much much worse than that or we
can have some dude walk into a women's
bathroom in loudoun county and brutalize
some girl
or
or i can get
worse and worse and worse and worse
all in the name of misguided compassion
and a misunderstanding of the world
when guests come up to my door this
holiday season
this is how i'm gonna greet them i'm
gonna greet them holding up these two
gigantic knives to show off the
incredible japanese steel that they are
made with kamikodo makes great japanese
steel kitchen knives using more than 800
years of traditional techniques from
japan each knife comes in a beautiful
wooden heavy duty box it makes sure that
the knives are stored safely and it
makes kamikodo a great gift each
kamikoto knife goes through a rigorous
19-step process that takes several years
from start to finish to complete the
expert blade smiths forage and shape raw
steel into hardy blades polishing and
sharpening them
to an excruciatingly fine edge each
knife is individually inspected kamikoto
is so confident about their knives that
each knife comes with a lifetime
guarantee i really strongly recommend it
kamikoto is currently having a massive
christmas sale and on top of that sale
you can get an additional dollars off
any purchase you make with discount code
knowles canada w l e s so click the link
below
or go to kamikoto.com slash knowles and
use promo code knowles canon wles to
save an extra 50 bucks today
did you like that clip be honest listen
you're not going to hurt my feelings and
i and i think i hope you like that clip
if you want to get more videos you got
to ring the bell
and subscribe and if you want to get all
the real notifications and not have our
friends in big tech
shut you up you got to go to apple
podcasts spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your podcasts type in
the michael knowles show subscribe leave
a five-star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]